ce matin je compte encore les choses
dans mon wagon il y en a six regardez
les choses écrire sur eux mais aussi sur
tous ceux qui fréquentent le métro un
métro qu'elle juge rassurant
sandrine senes vous entraîne au contact
d'anonymes utilisateurs du transport
parisien
les choses se sont imposés après comme
un fil conducteur non en clin d'oeil on
va dire à une histoire d'amour qui est
un peu lointaine aujourd'hui donc qui me
semble plus anecdotique mais ça s'est
rajouté c'est ça s'est imposée parce
qu'à une période de ma vie quand j'avais
besoin de faire des deuils donc d'une
histoire d'amour ou d'autre chose ça
peut être d'un travail ou des choses
plus graves
je suis toujours à les écrire dans le
métro défaire des portraits pour pour me
dire que je suis con qu'on n'est pas
seuls qu'on peut se frotter aux autres
et que les autres sont malheureux aussi
d'abord ouvrage je regarde passer les
chauves devient un seul en scène
sandrine c'est naze comme tour à tour
ses voyageurs il se met tout près de moi
et il me dit maman
c'est quand même intéressant j'ai pas
l'âge reste sa mère une création
possible grâce à la mise en scène signée
catherine vincennes et sam karmann
qu'elles rencontrent à l'occasion d'une
collaboration pour m6 c'est une super
comédienne est elle un vrai univers à
elle elle écrit ce bouquin qui nous
enchante et derrière la proposition a
été évidente
ce qui est bien avec le sandrine c'est
que à la mène tous il faut juste trier
choisir enlevé épuré allez je la trouve
très très drôle très poétique très
décalé sandrine senes vous fait
découvrir des personnages caricaturés
mais réelle des rencontres tour à tour
surprenante drôle et touchante